we begin with that school shooting there
is no school today in Santa Fe Texas
where people are mourning the shooting
deaths of ten people at a local high
school
dozens of people attended a candlelight
vigil last night for the victims we now
know the names of all of the eight
students and the two substitute teachers
who were killed Friday morning 13 others
at the school were hurt and we're
learning more about the suspects 17 year
old Demetrius pig or cheese
newly revealed video shows him
performing in a church festival
reportedly less than a week before the
attack
Omar Villafranca is outside Santa Fe
High School southeast of Houston
Omar still a tough morning there it is
good morning police reportedly
confronted the gunman just four minutes
after the first shots were fired and
that started a 25 minute gun battle a
school resource officer was shot before
the suspect finally gave up he's still
in custody but the main focus over the
weekend here in Santa Fe was on the
victims there are no words
take away that hurt pain through
multiple church services and vigils the
community of 13,000 came together to
honor the lives lost rights Texas
governor Greg Abbott greeted grieving
parishioners at this service Sunday
hundreds of worshippers attended this
mosque Sunday to remember Pakistani
exchange students Abeka Sheikh who
aspired to work in civil service Jolin
Cogburn was her US host mother on
Saturday night hundreds of fans packed
the stands at Santa Fe's playoff
baseball game two players even suited up
after being shot during the massacre a
day earlier police say 17 year-old
suspect Demetrius pug or cheese wore a
trench coat and carried a Remington 870
shotgun and a 38 caliber pistol during
the attack witnesses say he hovered
between four classrooms while taunting
students as he shot his classmates and
teachers lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
suggested Sunday that guns were not the
issue the best way to take that shooter
down is with a gun Patrick went on to
say school shootings could be prevented
by limiting the number of doors that
lead into campus you have the necessary
exits for fire of course but we have to
follow our students into our schools so
we can put eyes on them pug or cheese
surrendered to police a half hour after
they arrived to confront him he
immediately waived his Miranda rights
and is now in solitary confinement it's
certainly possible that the that that
wasn't a complete and knowing and
intelligent waiver Nicholas pale and
Robert far-field
represent pug or cheese they say their
client might not have been in the right
state of mind even though a social media
post before the shooting showed an
affinity for weapons and contained
violent messages this is a young kid
who's at this point very confused and I
think still in some shock
the suspects attorney says they've only
met with their client twice in total for
about an hour they do plan to talk to
him today we do not know when the next
court date is he faces capital murder
charges and also aggravated assault on a
peace officer and Houston Texans star JJ
Watt has offered to pay for the funerals
for all of the victims Gail JJ Watt
comes through once again such a sad
story it's becoming way too familiar to
us thank you